Quanto tempo demora em média para
proteger spike ser eliminada do
organismo? Bem, essa é uma questão muito
espinhosa e polêmica. Eu vou tentar aqui
fazer uma resposta equilibrada, mais
baseada em evidências e na minha opinião
pessoal, pelo que eu vejo no
consultório. E lembrando que muitos
médicos podem ter respostas
completamente diferentes, já que se
trata de um assunto que está longe de
ser pacificado e tem muita influência
política nisso, tá?
Contrariamente às alegações oficiais de
eliminação rápida, tem surgido cada vez
mais evidências científicas recentes,
demonstrando que a proteína spike
persiste no organismo por períodos muito
mais longos do que inicialmente se
pensava. Isso com consequências deletéas
graves para a saúde. Então, contrariando
as alegações oficiais de eliminação
rápida, tem evidências científicas
crescentes, demonstrando que a proteína
spike poderia persistir no organismo por
períodos prolongados e que gera
consequência que eu vou falar aqui. Eu
vou falar sobre evidência de
persistência prolongada, lembrando que
isso pode se aplicar tanto a proteína
spike selvagem quanto a versão
fabricada. Só que eu vou dar um
pouquinho mais de ênfase aqui na versão
fabricada. E lembrando que eu vou falar
aqui de uma maneira um pouco mais
indireta, que pode ser até considerada
enigmática para algumas pessoas. E se
você que escuta não estiver entendendo
exatamente o que eu tô dizendo, eu peço
paciência e peço que você analise com
calma depois esse vídeo, assista várias
vezes e faça uma pesquisa na internet
para poder entender melhor, porque eu
não posso ser mais claro do que isso.
Então, estudos recentes documentam a
persistência substancial da protein
spike muito além dos prazos que
originalmente se pensavam. Pesquisadores
da Universidade Eil detectaram protein
spike indivíduos com síndrome pós-picada
por mais de 700 dias após a última
picada, contrariando aquela ideia,
aquela alegação inicial de que tinha
eliminação em poucas semanas. Tem um
estudo também publicado no Science
Direct que demonstrou que a persistência
da proteína spike em artérias cerebrais
chegou a 17 meses pós picada
e ela estava localizada especificamente
na íntima das artérias cerebrais, que é
uma parte da parede da artéria. Então
essa descoberta é particularmente bem
preocupante dado a localização
estratégica do sistema vascular
cerebral. E teve também um grupo de
Patterson de uma universidade que
demonstrou persistência da proteína
Spike S1 em monóstito CD16S,
desculpa, CD16 mais por até 15 meses
após a infecção e mais recentemente
detectaram a proteína S1 em monóstito
CD16+
até 245 dias indivíduos com síndrome
póspicada. Isso confirmando por um exame
sofisticado chamado espectometria de
massa líquida. Bem, pesquisadores
utilizando técnicas de clareamento ótico
e de imagem observaram acúmulo da produt
spike no eixo crânio meninge cérebro,
né, na barreira meninge e sangue de
pacientes persistindo muito após o
clearance, né, a liberação dos vírus.
Então essa persistência promove
neuroinflamação, neurodegeneração e
vulnerabilidade
aumentada a lesões, OK? Lesões
cerebrais. Então, análises proteômicas
de amostras humanas de crânio, menin
cérebro revelaram vias inflamatórias
desreguladas e alterações associadas à
neurodegeneração. Então, a proteínio
RBD isolado, estimula a secreção da
citocina próinflamatória e teleocina um
beta e também enzimas proteíticas.
Desculpa tá falando tão difícil aqui,
mas eu tenho que apresentar a ciência
que dá suporte o que eu tô dizendo aqui,
tá? Em casos de miocardite pós picada,
pessoas que tiveram inflamação no
músculo cardíaco em adolescentes e
adultos jovens, eles tiveram níveis
circulantes persistentemente elevados da
proteína spike completa, não ligada por
anticorpos e foi detectável até três
semanas após a picada. Então essa
persistência à antigenemia observado na
síndrome inflamatória multissistêmica.
Em casos de trobcitopenia, ou seja,
queda das plaquetas induzido pela
picada, níveis do sangue de proteín
spike, 10 dias após a picada, foram 10
ng por ml, quase 100 vezes superiores ao
relatados indivíduos picados, sem
efeitos adversos, tá? pelo menos
aparentes. Isso sugere a produção
excessiva da proteína spike, que vai
atingir concentrações suficientemente
altas para se ligar de forma
significativa a alvos, como é o receptor
ACE2. E as nanopartículas lipídicas que
são utilizadas nessas soluções aí, né,
das picadas, provavelmente elas têm
distribuição ampla em vários tecidos e
órgãos humanos e podem exercer ação
pró-inflamatória junto com o RNA
mensageiro que tá empacotado ali. Então,
a ligação da proteína spike circulante
ao receptorar C2 e outros alvos,
juntamente com a possibilidade de
mimetismo molecular com proteínas
humanas, pode contribuir pros efeitos
adversos pós picada.
A síndrome póspicada inclui sintomas
como intolerância ao exercício, fadiga
excessiva, néva cerebral, insônia,
tontura e desenvolve-se pouco após a
picada e pode persistir ao longo de
muitos meses ou até anos. Então,
indivíduos com essa sínome apresentaram
maior probabilidade, evidência de
reativação do vírus e bar. Isso já tá
comprovado em vários estudos. Então,
pessoal, as evidências convergem para
demonstrar que longe de ser eliminada
rapidamente, a protein Spike, ela
persiste sim em múltiplos compartimentos
do organismo, em vários tecidos, por
meses a anos e pode causar inflamação
sustentada, disfunção vascular,
neurotoxicidade e desigulação do sistema
imune. Então essa persistência
prolongada explicaria a emergência de
eventos adversos, muitas vezes graves,
meses ou anos após picada, contrariando
as narrativas oficiais de segurança que
são baseadas em eliminação rápida.
Então, a localização da potência spike
em tecidos críticos, como é o caso do
cérebro, artérias cerebrais e também
células de defesa, monósitos
circulantes, isso representa um
mecanismo muito grave, muito preocupante
de doença e que demanda reconhecimento
clínico urgente pelos médicos. Lembrando
que a medicina funcional pode oferecer
abordagens terapêuticas para diminuir
esses efeitos através dos protocolos de
detoxa proteina spike e também melhora
de modo geral do sistema imune, tá? Boa
sorte, um grande abraço. Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça bem. A vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do Além do Tr se
envolva. Ah.